vamos a continuar con mi hábito de sobre
simplificar la economía entonces
imaginemos una economía solo con dos
actores tiene al señor granjero de aquí
déjame dibujar al granjero tiene su
bigote aquí tiene su barbilla ahí
tenemos al señor granjero que tiene su
sombrero para que no le queme el sol
entonces este de aquí es el señor
granjero de esta economía y además
tenemos un constructor entonces esta
economía está haciendo dos cosas verdad
número uno produce comida y este
constructor puede ayudar a hacer
reparaciones en las granjas este de aquí
es el señor constructor constructor muy
bien y supongamos que pues no sé por lo
que vamos a hacer ahorita supongamos que
en esta economía es una constante que si
cualquiera de estos cuates obtiene un
peso adicional entonces va a gastar 60
por ciento de eso déjame meter un
concepto que simplemente la definición
formal para decir esto mismo en esta
economía la propensión marginal al
consumo la propensión marginal
el consumo
con sumo
es de deja me pongo las siglas en
paréntesis la apm ce es igual a 60 por
ciento o bien podríamos decir que es
igual a 0.6 ok lo único que está
diciendo esto es que si alguien en esta
economía alguno de ellos dos obtiene un
peso entonces va a gastar el 60 por
ciento el 60 por ciento de ese peso o
sea 60 centavos si le das al constructor
un peso él va a gastar 60 centavos y
sólo lo puede gastar con el granjero
verdad si el viajero tiene un peso
entonces se va a gastar 60 centavos
haciendo reparaciones pagándose los al
constructor bueno dada esta suposición
vamos a ver qué sucedería en esta
situación si de repente uno de ellos
decide aumentar su gasto entonces
supongamos que habita la economía está
muy feliz todo está muy tranquilo en un
estado estable pero el granjero digamos
que descubre un calcetín en su cajón que
tiene un montón de dinero tiene mil
pesos pesos o dólares o lo que sea que
ellos estén usando como moneda
entonces supongamos que habitas son
pesos vale entonces el granjero descubre
que tiene un calcetín
mil pesos así que no se esperaba es muy
padre encontrar dinero en un calcetín
pero dice sabes que los voy a gastar los
voy a gastar con el constructor entonces
el granjero tiene este aumento en gasto
verdad entonces el granjero dice sabes
que voy a gastar mil pesos aquí se los
voy a dar el constructor luego el
constructor es de guau recibí mil pesos
que no me esperaba pero sabes que tengo
una propensión marginal al consumo de 60
por ciento o de 0.6 y entonces voy a
gastar sobre el 60 por ciento entonces
gasta 60 por ciento con el granjero vaya
no hay nadie más con quien lo pueda
gastar pero entonces gasta el 60 por
ciento de mil pesos eso de ahí es igual
a 600 pesos muy bien ahora granjero dice
guau
ahora recibir 600 pesos verdad sea gaste
mil y de repente la economía me regreso
600 pesos entonces cómo tengo 600 pesos
verdad que usualmente no tendría ahora
lo que voy a hacer es ponerme a gastar y
como tengo una profesión marginal
consumo de 60 por ciento los voy a
gastar pero solo voy a gastar el 60% de
eso
entonces el granjero gastaría el 60 por
ciento de esta cantidad de a cada déjame
le escribo lo voy a escribir como un
decimal sería 0.6 multiplicado por esta
cosa que es lo voy a poner así 0.6 por
mí
o bien pues es 60 por ciento de 600 que
es lo mismo que 360 pesos misma idea
cabe constructor tiene 360 pesos que no
contemplaba entonces llegaron 360 pesos
dice tengo una propensión marginal al
consumo de 60 por ciento y entonces
ahora voy a gastar el 60 por ciento de
esto de aquí entonces además de este
gasto va a hacer otro gasto adicional el
60 por ciento de 360 y el 60 por ciento
de 360 es punto 6 por eso de ahí sería
punto 6 x esta cantidad lo voy a poner
en un paréntesis por 0.6 por 0.6 por
ahí está algo de este estilo y ahora
este número de aquí pues la verdad no sé
cuánto sea es el 60 por ciento de 360
déjame sacar la calculadora para hacer
las cuentas entonces pues es lo mismo
que de ponerle 0.6 al cubo por mil
verdad es punto 63.6 por punto 6 por
punto 6 o sea puntos 6 elevado al cubo
déjame lo pongo así elevado al cubo y
luego hay que multiplicarlo por mil por
mil ok me da 216 pesos sale entonces
este cuarto el constructor ahora gasta
216 pesos el granjero dice lo mismo
ahora tengo 216 voy a gastar el 60% creo
que ver la idea verdad ya estoy
volviéndome muy repetitivo pero déjame
acabar con esto de acá el punto 6 por
ciento de esta última cantidad que
escribí entonces va a ser 0.6
multiplicado por esto de acá que pues ya
tiene 3 0.6 es verdad entonces sería 0.6
elevado a la cuarta multiplicado por mil
entonces es 0.6 a la cuarta multiplicado
por mil pesos eso de ahí es igual a 2.6
de 216 déjame hacerlo nada más para que
nos queden los numeritos entonces es eso
por punto 6 que es 129 pesos con 60
centavos 129 pesos con 60 centavos
el constructor dice lo mismo tengo 129
pesos con 60 centavos voy a seguir
haciendo este ciclo y seguimos y
seguimos y seguimos bueno pensemos un
poquito qué sucedió con este incremento
inicial de mil pesos al final de ccoo
que tanto se aumentó en total la
producción y el gasto bueno depende de
tu perspectiva verdad la forma en la
cual lo pensamos es que el total de otra
vez te digo lo puedes pensar como la
producción total el producto interno
bruto como el gasto total en fin depende
mucho de tu punto de vista pero son
equivalentes porque si alguien gasta le
da dinero a alguien más pero ahorita
vamos a ponerle que vamos a ponerle la
producción total sale la producción
total cuánto aumentó ahorita digamos en
pesos cuánto sería saber son estos mil
pesos originales verdad que gastó el
granjero serían mil pesos más y luego
cuanto más pues lo que pagó éste aquí
sería punto seis por mil que fue 600
pesos pero lo pongo como punto 6
multiplicado por mil para que veamos el
patrón más luego estamos aquí verdad en
esta ocasión es punto 6 por punto 6 por
mil entonces es más 0.6 al cuadrado
multiplicado por mil
más y este cuate ahora dice bueno ahora
es el 60% de puntos 6 al cuadrado o 6
puntos 6 por 0.6 al cuadrado esto le da
esta cosa de acá que es 0.6 al cubo
verdad 0.6 al cubo multiplicado por mil
mil pesos y luego siguió verdad la
última la última ronda que hicimos pero
que podríamos seguir fue punto seis a la
cuarta deja me muevo a la derecha es más
0.6 elevado a la cuarta por mil pesos
muy bien esto puede seguir y seguir
insisto que puede seguir así
infinitamente puede ser punto seis a la
quinta por mí y luego más punto seis a
la sexta por mil y seguir y seguir ahora
la cosa padre de matemáticas que se va a
aparecer por aquí es lo siguiente es que
aunque aquí tengamos una suma infinita
una serie si sumamos todos todos estos
términos como el valor de aquí es 0.6 y
está entre 0 y 1 entonces toda esta suma
infinita acaba siendo sólo un número
eso está muy bueno estamos sumando una
infinidad de términos pero al final de
cuentas la suma es un número finito
entonces el total sería vamos a
factorizar el mil déjame factorizar lo
en color
cosa entonces es mil x y que nos
quedaría si sacamos un mil aquí es un 1
más 0.6 más 0.6 al cuadrado más 0.6
elevado al cubo más 0.6 elevado a la
cuarta más y así sucesivamente sigue y
sigue ahora en este vídeo no lo voy a
demostrar quizás lo deje para el
siguiente vídeo pero toda esta expresión
de aquí es una suma infinita de una
progresión geométrica y se puede
simplificar esto de aquí se simplifica
dejarlo como en verde a 1 entre 1 menos
0.6 entonces cualquier numerito que
tengamos aquí sería 1 entre 1 menos eso
y en este caso a ver cuánto nos quedaría
esto es uno entre 10.630 punto 41 entre
0.4 y esto cuánto es 0.4 es dos quintos
entonces es uno entre dos quintos que es
lo mismo que cinco medios y cinco medios
es 2.5 grit hago la cuenta total pero
entonces la producción total sería igual
a mil pesos multiplicados por
5 medios esto de aquí es 2.5 entonces es
1000 por 2.5 y esto de aquí es igual a
2500 pesos entonces hay dos cosas
interesantes aquí verdad número uno es
esto de acá es de esta idea de la
propensión marginal al consumo o sea que
la gente sólo gasta una parte de lo que
recibe en este caso era un 0.6 o bien un
60% y 'número dos' es que dado eso se
empieza a hacer un ciclo verdad se
empieza a multiplicar multiplicar y
multiplicar y entonces tenemos un efecto
multiplicador se gasta se gasta y luego
es una fracción y entonces al final de
cuentas lo que acaba sucediendo es que
esos mil pesos que añadimos a la
economía se multiplican aquí por 2.5
pero vaya lo que está bueno es que en
general este 2.5 viene de la propensión
marginal al consumo entonces tenemos
esta relación de aquí cualquiera que sea
la propensión marginal al consumo esto
te da el multiplicador y bueno a final
de cuentas este multiplicador lo que
dice es lo siguiente
dice por cada peso que metas a la
economía por cada peso adicional cuántos
pesos más se generan en términos de
producción o de gasto